Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones and hear
from the most important people in the David Pakman
show universe. The audience. Let's go to. Oh, I
don't know. How about Ramiro from Indiana? Welcome
to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, I had a quick question on,
I guess, comparing the U.S.. Executive branch
and the way the system works in Argentina.
So the vice president that they had
a quote unquote assassination attempt
recently. So she had been the president
before. Yeah. So in their system,
she can become the. I'm sorry.
Yes. She was the president.
She can become the vice president. Because here,
from my understanding, like Barack Obama would
not be able to be the vice president. Correct.
Speaker 1: So I don't remember the answer to
that in the U.S.. Can if you've been president?
You know, I think you can be vice president. But
if you if the president were to die, it
would skip to the speaker of the House.
Maybe people can fact check me on that. Yeah.
Because at one point there was the idea of
Biden should pick Obama as his as his VP.
Speaker 2: Obama? I didn't know that was
actually an option, but yeah, I'll have to look
in on that. I know. The only question I had so.
Speaker 1: Well, how are things in Indiana?
Speaker 2: Of the same as always,
I guess. Not great, not terrible.
Speaker 1: And is everybody
thrilled that Mike Pence is back?
Speaker 2: Well, you know, it's funny because
everyone in Indiana didn't like Mike Pence until
he became the vice president ticket running mate.
So I don't understand. People are silly here.
Speaker 1: Right. All right. Well,
keep on keeping on. All right.
Speaker 2: All right. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much. Always great to
hear from folks in Indiana, a very powerful state.